today we have the good ocean breeze
adjunct professor
yeah it's Mila and also leading team
income job and you will give us a talk
about the progress and chances in your
name with Missa
well thank you where am I supposed to
yeah well I see there's a camera yeah
yeah so I guess what I is and in fact
last time I gave a version of I
essentially went over like went really
quick on the last part I might make turn
this into a like maybe I'll come back
and get from the last part which is more
or looking and perhaps yeah make the
most out of the next hour and a lot of
this is going over literature and a lot
of it not my own even just to give you a
sense of when it's been done hopefully
you know from this you can kind of build
on these ideas yeah ideas for future
research for yourself so I came to start
working on this topic because generally
speaking when I went started being a
faculty require broad research agenda
was this was based on this function that
well and this observation that in deep
learning we've had all the success
because we have a lot of training data
and then that's add impact in many
industries applications and so on
but of course requires collecting all of
that data and the assumption here is
that that's not going to be sufficient
for us to really reach a group abilities
or all the different problems we'd like
to use machine learning to solve
collecting young billions of examples
for each individual ability that the
system should have it's not much more
reasonable than say when we're thinking
about expert systems many years ago when
we would just try to dump as much expert
knowledge into a machine for every
single ability so and also the fact is
that the Cyclopes we do learn way faster
than our current you know machine
learning based system but there's also
this kind of gap scientifically speaking
we don't understand and our ability to
learn fast and the ability machines to
learn much more slowly and so there's
approaches or trying to address this
particular something more simple
efficient than this learning new things
faster different approaches that people
like myself and others have looked at is
either well it's actually looking at
other sources of data for work doing
some sort of transfer to a new task
either you use unlabeled data so the
unsupervised learning to learn
representation or some form of
semi-supervised learning you might look
at multimodal data thinking that if you
have an additional modalities so if
you're learning on images have some text
give you the text provide some sort of
weak labels indirectly about what you
actually want to learn in the prediction
you want to think all right or you can
try to do multi domain data so you
leverage data that's available for
certain tasks that are somewhat similar
to the one you want to solve so that
relates to domain adaptation and in
general to transfer learning and that's
really in this particular approach that
that few shots learning and the meta
learning approaches I'll talk about fall
into today the one problem to keep in
mind for this whole presentation is
essentially illustrated here what we are
trying to do is we would like to solve a
problem where there are training set
actually corresponds to very very few
examples per class and we'll just focus
on constipation will focus on image
classification largely because we
actually know that we're our selves
really good at doing that understanding
and object category from a few examples
visual examples in this case at five
classes only one example for class
there's something here that thing the
dog near the lion and some bolt and in
the task is from this training set
that's small how can I infer the label
and I classify the image of this line
here in this bowl successful you're
assuming that the test examples are
drawn from one of the categories under
the trainer yeah so that's the setting
where we're considered it's one where
someone has provided us some labels on
some classes and that person wants a
system that will later on classify other
examples from fences and so yeah part of
the reason that I find this interesting
outside of the fact that I think in
terms of applications this would be
variable is that people are good at it
there's also scientifically like
something that we don't quite understand
that's a gap between but we learn that
the way visions learn so this is an
example that jumps ten developing games
you know it's hard to give these
examples of new objects and give that
talk multiple times because then you've
in that whole time and you know
presumably you look for that object on
the web after but you know most people
if they see the something of this
technically like thing then they'll be
able to identify what is another segue
in image it's geared and we've seen
pretty good progress on so long simpler
problems using ideas like transfer
learning and meta learning so this is
also from Josh Tenenbaum group where I
did in nature a method that was able to
classify characters from new alphabets
and it was doing this by transferring
this ability of doing that that was
trying on a set of training alphabet and
we're reaching the
performance of though one sort of
concrete illustration of how people
could use this and the type of problem I
have in mind when I think of why am i
you know trying to solve you know get
better performance on this day a few
shots learning data set would be one
where VZ haps
somewhat interacting with a machine
providing their data for some classifier
to want to train and being able to do
this without the intervention of a
machine learning expert the one example
of the Guinness this little activity I
did for my Gibbs where we'll trying a
pacifier from my webcam camera this is
on the teaching machines website that's
an experiment with Google where you can
sort of play with various experiments
they put and design in the browser this
is what about kind of teaching about you
know what it is to collect data then and
how this impacts your classifier but we
would like to do four instances to be
able to train the tree glass classifier
from simple images with tape so in this
case I go in my webcam and then I'll do
classifier where it's either acting by
smelling if I'm yawning or if do and I'd
like to live it just by pushing on the
first funding button and you can see
when I make the once I collected my data
it gets the problem correctly but what
you want is to generalize if I ask my
older daughter to try it out
initially if she smells it always keeps
predicting the last class which is yeah
then what you'd like is for anyone to be
able to kind of collect the data
themselves in this case you know collect
images of her smiling of her yawning and
over being scared and then you know
hopefully that after that it works isn't
works for and and we'd like to one able
to do this without the intervention of a
machine learning person
you collect data and it adapts
immediately so that they are other
sister comes in then hopefully it works
in this case she's files and then it's
green purple when she yawns and I was
able to generalize them from a cute
example in this example it's there are a
few reasons why you know it works first
of all we tried a bunch of other three
classification problems a lot of them
weren't working so this is was the one
that actually like ended up producing
this demo from a few examples but in
fact is most of the times that like it
requires many more examples also the
generalization here that's asked is a
bit easier you know there are sisters so
they supposed to share half of my genes
you were to take this and then go in
another setting with a different
background most likely with but if we
have something that could just work that
easily that anyone can collect images
with their camera I'd like to get in
visual possible because imagine this
being very used and if you could do this
for more than just in this
classification again I think this this
could have a lot of impact alright so so
that's kind of you know what we're after
and then the type of problems that we
think we've been solving who were better
at at a few shots were the few shops
learning is this problem we're assumed
that or any new given problem we have a
small training set that's really what
makes the shoe shop learning problem and
people have thought a lot about how to
address this particular setting in the
past and I'll go over you know sort of
older literature on the topic what
approach definitely recently I started
being making progress in going beyond
what's done before is the idea that when
we're doing to shop learning really what
we want is a learning out of them movie
a that produces a models in the
parameters of some model some model and
when it's better sit book
the algorithm is medicine for this
training said we want to learning
algorithm that produces good parameters
that generalizes well to you example and
the universe will take you the meta
learning is will treat 8 as a model that
loop strength is we will learn the
learning algorithm that's why we call
that failure so before I go into the
various approaches for this sort of
talking about related work in that that
space that's perfectly there's been a
lot of success already in particular
images we all know that a lot of times
if you pre train a model of image net
that will give you a good inventing good
representation that transfers pretty
well to other tasks sometimes
surprisingly different tasks like for
cases of things like medical imaging
tasks and so on but often with this
reviser you do the pre-training we take
some you know you down it's a model
that's been pre training already and
then you use that as the paternity but
you still do a fair amount of work like
you know potentially tuning the hyper
parameters of the learning rates and
things like this in a sense what we
would like to do here with many of these
few shuffling methods is that we don't
want to have all of this network that
happens after we just state the
initialization but you still need to do
things like tweak to model the learning
rate some about regularization and so on
so far you would like that to be as
black box as possible and that whole
process of it transferring to only data
set to be effectively per there's also
been yes what you share between all
these yes that's right yeah so we'll do
a former is especially the stuff I'm
talking about here it is doing a form of
transferring but I think what we're
after is that once we've done with the
mental learning there's no like posed
sort of tuning of learning rates and
things like that it should just be a
black box on one kit because right now
the way we do transfer learning is we
download this model but they're still on
machine learning you know experts or
scientists
it's you need the learning rates for it
and Swanson and also Louise while
transfer learning sort of works often
really the success to get this still
quite dependent on having a lot of data
forth deep target net so there's a lot
of literature also on one-shot learning
which is this extreme pains of you
shopping we have just one example some
of these papers actually even though
they label themselves as being one-shot
learning deep sometimes present
experiments would be varied the number
of examples they have four unique tasks
um a lot of that literature actually was
you know pre sort of deep learning
revolution where people were using and
design features for representing images
and so in a sense what we're trying to
do here is we're kind of revisiting that
problem but we're kind of leveraging the
success of that with end-to-end learning
this case both to feature so and then
learn the feature representation that's
useful for transfer learning and also we
want to enter and learn the whole
process of doing that adaptation as well
as opposed to sort of defining say some
graphical models that does the transfer
learning in some way want to actually
enter and learn it all right don't a few
definitions first what is the learning
algorithm that's the thing that we'll be
learning it makes sense to define that
to make sure under well they feel what
I'm learning out with them the learning
algorithm is a that takes as input a
training set it will some examples x and
y's where X is the input and it outputs
either a model will see the parameters
of some model which on sometimes
referred to as the learner and what we
think of a learning about album that
being a good algorithm is one where the
performance of that model that's
produced by the learning algorithm is
good on some new examples some test set
that is different from that's what the
learning algorithm is so a meta learning
algorithm will be as follows it will
because it's a learning out of it it
also tastes a training set but in our
setting it's going to be a meta
it's a minute trading sense because that
training set would correspond to many
trying test success so often these pairs
of training and test sets will refer to
these as as an episode and our meta
learning algorithm is also going to
output parameters with the parameters
and outputs conceptually are the
parameters of a learning algorithm
itself that is an algorithm aid that can
take in a training set and then produce
a model that can be evaluated on the
test set for some episode and again
instead of learning we're interested
like a good mentor learning algorithm is
one that will generalize a meta test set
okay and this meta test set well it also
has episodes as part of it that is other
splits of a training set and a
corresponding test and that's where we
evaluate our performance all right that
clear if there are questions about this
and they're easy on please don't
hesitate then yes so the output of the
vehicle learning algorithm or the
parameter of the yeah that's right
yes yeah this is but that's right yes
conceptually that's that's that's how we
think of data line in other questions
and I want to emphasize that this notion
here of we evaluate the performance on a
meta test set this data test set is
really should be different problems
different problems on what you've seen
that training time I think you can yes
so yeah no that's a good question so it
depends on which meta learning algorithm
would lose so some meta money Islands
assumes a particular form for what the
learner would look like
it's rice so for instance if you think
of it as let's say I think you're
familiar with mammal which is
essentially this approach we're back
propagate the dissent in mammal you
learned the initialization and maybe
parameters of the gradient descent
procedure and those would be the
parameters of their metal earner but
then novel when you fit a training set
of an episode it produces parameters of
say a complan and those would be the
parameters of the learner the learner
would be the cop that and not all the
meta learning algorithm learns and
initialization and potentially learning
rates to use at different time steps
that's what the distinction happens
sometimes that distinction is is not as
clear-cut and so that's why this in the
context of a gradient based metal
learner that separation is easier but
there's some learners that really like
you know don't walk clear distinction
between what the learner is alright but
so the point I wanted to make is that I
think sometimes we refer to various
things as being meta learning from my
perspective we're doing mental learning
that we are interested in learning out
of them and we are interested in
generalization so say if you're doing
hyper parameter search and it's a
finding one that works well for C far
depart that but you never actually look
at there's nothing in the progress being
in the prior search procedure or the
sorry the hyper parameter architecture
search procedure that's being learned
and there's no evaluation on how this or
any you know architecture search
procedure generalizes to new problems
then as far as happens with it's not
through the meta learning it's it's
deciding an optimizer perhaps for a
particular problem but you're not
looking at generalization to new
problems and to me that's like a key for
something to be better learning I think
there's people will have their own
perspective as to what makes a meta
learning algorithm a proper meta
learning algorithm mine is probably like
I've seen people being pretty
restrictive as to what the define is now
learning that to me as long as you're
learning a procedure that takes a
training set
and produces a model that can make
prediction on some new examples and that
you're evaluating on problems it's never
seen before this I think technically
speaking that's a meta learning
procedure the definition you gave before
wasn't that wasn't a minimal set that is
your go back yeah
did that the D meta test could be
ostensibly like the D prime train could
be empty then in that case the one that
is easy just describe deep frying grain
could be anything
yeah but you're just doing
generalization to some other test
come on their domain or some other
distribution my guess here I didn't
write it explicitly but he better train
and he made a test should be different
super different the question is is do
you require training in this new domain
or to be meta learning so there's no
adjustment of the learning algorithm
itself on the tester it is better than
anything you're both the base learner
this will be a function of prime train
but the changes for each episode or each
episode in the meta test set
it will change I guess what I'm asking
is you consider zero shot transfer to a
new domain so W is it's not quite
fuchsia learning in the sense that we
kind of assume here that the training
examples are examples C workshop
learning is even harder where you
actually have a description of the task
though it doesn't fit that that
description and when I look at a few
shot learning paper I don't expect to
see or software experiments I think it
could somewhat argue that if you're
looking at generalizations in the
descriptions there's a sense in which it
is doing their learning time might be
inclined to include that in the setting
of life as long as you're looking at the
evaluation of new problems and new
descriptions of problems you never
trained on that I think yeah but really
there is a form of learning procedure
that's happening but
yeah I'm not sure I'm not I'm not sure
exactly where but I feel it's just
tweaking definitions at this point so I
don't know on useful engine so in
America tracking said what you would I
think it would have essentially like I
wouldn't need to think I didn't expect
[Laughter]
training examples we also have for each
class you have like meta data a bit
description of so here and there there
would be additional data which is for
each class and what's the description of
it that is not selling grounded
explicitly in images I go in some stuff
that people do is like they use a
Wikipedia article of the describing that
object count yeah I read that transfer
to a new distribution is the most
interesting problem but it was to be
like hyper optimization even from the
same distribution is like you're
learning how to do optimization of
architecture to get better translation
person it's the same distribution your
are making you resemble but if you're
using the same training and test set is
that effectively but then you're not
looking at local training allows the
focus on foundation so for meets it
that's where the distinction so I guess
it is true you're looking at the the
optimizing the validation set error on
the validation sets when you're doing
after prime research and then you're
looking at well on new examples from
those classes and but that is not really
impressive
I but that's like the most common thing
to do no because distributions here are
over pass and I would argue it's the
same task if you haven't generalize
across them but Johnny generalize across
your definition is what it's time to
finish I think I preface this by saying
according to me but you're restricted to
that multi I guess I'll tell you why you
think it's a good thing to define it
this way is that it to me it means that
we're going to be more ambitious as to
the problems we're going to be solving
because and I'm saying that
architectures which shouldn't be a
problem people study I'm just saying
that it confusing that with other work
that is doing now learning that is
actually looking at generalization
across fast that's who he is is harder
in terms of generalization and so I
think it's it's deserving of its own
category yes I did backdrop to learn how
to parameters in Japan thank you so yeah
but architectural search is I mean
they're similar yes there's some
similarities with your point except for
what you can search these are different
problems yes so some people for instance
have I think I think there must be
examples of this way they actually have
trying some sort of agent that is doing
architectural search and maybe it has
parameters inside it that does that
that process and if then they looked at
say that they tried it on C bar R 10 and
then they looked at okay well does it
find under how compromise were C far 100
then to me like that's that the police
is a form of generalization that that I
think is in alright so I want to go over
the literature a little bit and not just
by opinion sort for y'all right so in
this setting where we're doing beveling
try to make things more visual our
approach to doing that money is as
follows we want to generalize to this
problem it's an episode as the training
set as a test set and what we're
assuming here is that we're gonna have
this is like and we're assuming it's
part of the meta test step and then we
also got to have a meta training set
with other episode other splits and
training in and importantly the way we
usually set up to the way we essentially
make this a generalization we make these
test set examples different is that we
don't just assume the different images
we also assume they're from different
fossils that's how we're gonna have some
difference between the training and the
test so some of the others point this is
not I am assembling of the training and
test set the test step is coming from a
different distribution from the training
set this is partly we could do the ID
sampling if we had such a large set of
tasks in terms of classes that I be
something will be double D is you know
substantial difference between the
training and test set but you know for a
lot of these data sets out there like
for instance mini [ __ ] it's a couple
hundred classes you could do the
thousand ones but even then you would
end up probably sampling almost you know
exactly the same set of problems in
terms of classes in class but the way
these episodes are created is as follows
so initially or a lot of these
benchmarks for the meta training set we
take a subset of the classes of a larger
dataset so medium is that which is one
that's used a whole lot that I'll refer
to often is already a subset of 100
classes from image yeah from that 100
subset 64 were put aside for generating
meta
training emphasis and then when we
create an episode the process we do is
that we pick a random subset of five
classes from these 64 and those are the
classes are going to use to generate one
episode and for each class to generate
the training set of the episode we take
randomly some examples from that class
for each class in this case I just
picked one example for five shot of
classification it would be five examples
and for the test set we pick another set
of randomly selected but different
images from that same time and then the
meta test set in the image that is
another's this thing step of twenty
classes from that same same first set of
a hundred faster so that's how we make
the problem is different and so is your
get either some new classes or you mean
in another test or yeah yeah yeah for
sure
is their third so this is 64 classes
okay and these are other twenty that are
not assessed before classes okay but
they come from this hundred set of
Bascom image that that's how we
construct a meta learning benchmark from
an existing case there's some reason why
we're only picking six before classes
like why not use like almost a thousand
and yeah I think this the oriole came up
with the initial setup I've never asked
him why did this I think it's largely so
that the problem is smaller but even
though you could argue that even is more
positive you know I mean you could
imagine that if you have 64 class is
going to overfit earlier so you're gonna
train that is long and so that's like a
smaller problem I think that's our key
invalidation I'm not sure that maybe the
beta to the Towson categories how many
of the
but it's not just remembering which one
because there's also you're not going to
see the same image in the in the
training setting
so what's the closest thing and some
methods explicitly are doing this and
but they are meta trained in the way
that they can do that successfully
end-to-end yeah yeah so I mean to me
that's addressing that's an interesting
pension and maybe touch on that a bit
more later but that's a trick that
people use to get a better
initialization of a meta learning and
that to me is is fine that's like one
trick over it's like you know whatever
optimized are using for meta learning
that's another dimension Explorer so to
me that's more part of life are you
successful at training a meta learner as
long as you're showing that you know you
actually are moving over the
initialization
yeah so but often even better learning
algorithms that use and retrain Matalan
imagenet and again here you need to do
we train on just these 64 classes and
not others because otherwise you'd be
cheating because these twenty five stars
per minute
normally they they like say for mammal
for I didn't talk about that yeah I
square lots of them so you often use
that to initialize the initialization
use that's framed by mammal and normally
also tuning that is important so you
know don't keep that fence so to me the
short answer is if you're using a pre
training model and regular say 64 we
classification to initialize you're
effectively trying to address what is
why we don't quite understand which is
seems like training some of the meta
learning Islands is difficult and using
these initializations
that come that are based on the same
data tends to somehow improve the
performance yes no they're also from the
subsets of images it's ten so I mean if
you do take a featuring model first you
should make sure that we train model has
never seen any data from these 20
classes that's for sure and that's what
people now if the question is isn't a
cheating that they both come from the
same you know overarching data set I
think what it means is that it's making
the generalization
problem easier it's hard and considering
the same set of classes with different
images but it's but it's not enough
that makes cribbage and so you sort of
iterate over episodes they can use mini
batches of episodes also but every time
we usually do some form of gradient
descent on the and then ultimately
reevaluate the performance on episodes
on the meta test set
all right now a few words about the
language er so I will try to use as up
as I can to follow into the main culture
which is that in episodes that's a
essentially a bigger point in my mentor
training set is a parable training and
test set and that means that my training
set and my meta trainees in my meta test
set they have each episodes or pairs of
training and testing and there are other
papers that instead will refer to the
training set in the episode as to
supports them and then the test set in
an episode is the query set and that
allows them to use training and test set
for referring to what would otherwise be
the Mediterranean met at SF it makes
presentations much easier and less
confusing that's cool so I tend to use
the potential that aren't you for that
reason but you should be aware going
into paper's like the in production that
we like to skip something we'll identify
which one they're actually and I might
slip in the support set or Thursday
accidentally I will try to stick to one
of them in terms of what is typically
the last continuity the prediction of
the model produced by a metal learner on
the test set of an episode often we
essentially used a cross entropy loss on
the fast label assignments you can kind
of think of it as evaluating this last
function where you're doing a prediction
over the label of some new input X prime
I and that's effectively also
conditioned on the training set of that
episode okay so the whole level learning
procedure we can think of it as
essentially giving you a way of a model
for this what is the distribution over
the label of a new example
X
right and then you're trying to minimize
that average negative log probability so
try to assign high probability to the
correct class of these new examples for
that problem or effectively that
information about what that problem is
is provided by the training set so the
capital data is effectively part of the
melon or that's that's what your your
meta learning yeah one thing is P of
capital theta as a function of P
training is basically it gives you a
data which gives you this so what is a
function of the train was the lower case
there the capital then of that the
procedure that takes in the training set
then produces the model alright so and
the time I have left I will hopefully
cover all of this so I like to think
directly once we define how you know
there are the way we approach meta
learning you know this episode ik
framework what we're doing great at this
end of your episodes Dan what's left is
how do we paralyze learning algorithms
that's kind of the model aspect of it we
can think of various ways of defining a
learning algorithm that we can not
propagate into and I like to think of
this there being like two types though
again like most things that it's hard to
put a strong threshold between various
categories but I do think of it as there
being two types of approaches there's
one where we will prioritize all
learning algorithm by taking inspiration
from a known learning out and we will
just take that learning algorithm it
will introduce new parameters maybe in
it or some existing parameters will glow
will become trainable and well I'll go
over instance matching networks which
you can think of as try is that taking
inspiration from a key nearest neighbor
learning out of them or a kernel machine
if you're using a Gaussian classifier
take inspiration from that the gauchos
aspirins
the men in space that's effectively for
the typical Network if you want to think
of using great and descent and by
propagating through beta descent
approaches like like their work on
middle and rail STM and mammal also is
effectively leveraging that auditing
approach that's one way and the other
quotes is just you know give up on all
of our inspiration or all of the prior
art on learning algorithms and just be
like let's throw a neural network at it
that we know can get it can take as
input a step and can make predictions of
new examples doesn't matter if it's
close or not to learning a little is
just defining tensile photograph
effectively that takes in a training set
and can make prediction on a new test
example and it's trained it to become a
learning algorithm to make new
predictions successfully on new examples
and the examples of that are a mane and
tail which alright so let's talk about
the first category when we take
aspiration of a known learning algorithm
the first one and which is one of the
early papers that in particular proposed
the medium is death benchmark which
people use a lot now it's effectively
training a learning album that just does
pattern matching that is what it does is
that it it will take the training set
here and we'll have an embedding
function that produces a particular
representation of each of these examples
we also have a potentially different
embedding function that takes in the
test example in the episode these will
be compared with some distance function
and that function will determine a
weight so this is the ultimate thing
with that distance function we will
obtain a normalized weight over that
effectively determines how each training
example in the training set will vote
and the weight of its vote towards its
only class assignment for this test
example X hat and the way this was
parrot rise is that we have two
different functions for the test
inventing the test example and embedding
the training example in the episode and
then we just think so
a similarity function pass that through
the software and that's how we obtain
these points if you think of the labels
y:i as being of one contactor you're
essentially just averaging with some
weights determined by Easterns here
you're averaging one hot pack ters which
will give you a distribution over tables
and that becomes your pia y for the test
example and then to the paper they've
considered doing things like just having
the same embedding function for both G
and F and and sort of separately
embedding each example either on the
training set or the test set and then
using that but it also looked at in the
eight got better results on the Internet
by having some more complicated a
recurrent neural net that would actually
take in the full set put it in some
arbitrary order and then just go left
and right to get a sort of task specific
representation in this sort of more
generic way I'm gonna go over the
details of these architectures we can
look them up there but it's actually the
short story is they kind of take this
kernel machine like equation they draw
in their own nets at it and they trying
those neural nets to make good
predictions on on the test set given the
train it's nice for me it's a little
tough to see this is like learning to
learn right it's more like you're
learning to solve this task which is
kind of a I'm in a one shot house that I
kind of view this more like a task
description like this this task sample
is going to be one of these things but
just to see this is meta learning it's
to me it sounds like a lot of what is
doing is that yes but it's not the
reason why it's not just a
representation in their paper they don't
have the representation in the sense of
like it's an embedding they apply
uniformly to all examples
they have looked at creating a
representation for each examples taking
into account and it says step and that
there's something encoded in all of
these examples together as well but it
is embracing the notion that is a set of
G's applied for each no that's there's
one version which is a bi-directional
record your own narrative and that's the
one that was passed on Univision M in
that census that's right yes I think to
answer our these points gained in its
simplest learning algorithm where you
don't think it's turning well so you
know if we can't agree on this then just
don't point that we will have
repercussions as to what is now learning
that way which I mentioned the typical
Network you can effectively think of it
as finding a good representation that
works well for a Gaussian possible and
it's been pretty effective that's it's
one of the methods out there that often
has pretty solid performance and at some
don't consider meta learning so here
what we're doing is that instead of
having this pattern match for that
comparison test example in some
representation space to each individual
example in the training set of the
episode we're first going to extract
some sort of summary of that class with
a prototype in that paper the way they
extract the prototype is by actually
taking the average of some hidden layer
essentially some embedding space that's
the output of a neural net and that's
going to be if you do this for all
examples in class game that's gonna give
you the prototypes ETA and then to get a
distribution over the label of a new
example X you will compare the embedded
test input with the corresponding
prototype of each class and calculate
the distance take the negative
to get a similarity and and passes
through softener okay so that's like
really really simple and that already
gives pretty good performance and the
way you can think of it as as mental
earning is that you're learning a
representation that works well for a
calcium capsule it's it's truly for
Gaussian classifier if the distance
function is the squared distance but you
can use other distances it's it's one
where for each class you essentially
trying the Gaussian density model so you
compute it to me and let's say you make
the assumption which most people do in
culture class where's that it's the same
covariance matrix across classes as
missing no because you compare with the
mean that's each individual example it
is not just computing the mean and easy
use the same covariance across classes I
mean effectively if you want to think of
this as a caption classifier the
predicted function might be similar to
also Fisher discriminant analysis
because there's you know and the
learning of them there's not just like
the model itself and it makes
predictions is also all you train which
is not much different from the other one
yes you have this bottleneck no matter
how many examples there are the you need
to summarize this all into your full
effect
but on the mini image that exam task
cast that collapsed almost so we will do
five shots classification not just one
shot it's just easier to show just one
image
oh is that it's always like that it's
people tend to do one and five shot okay
but I mean and you're moving no we
should do more yeah
as you're basically big things with very
simple symmetrical that's might be true
where I the fact that we're comparing to
a prototype today makes this less about
but I think a similar issue at the
molarity metric learning I think more
vineyards name think more of comparing
examples with examples where asks the
prototype here is sure living in the
same dimensional space but you compare
your learning a representation such that
prototypes and test examples are
comparable yeah that's what I think you
can think of at this time all right a
few things to say about this
so yeah the distance function actually
can be anything but if it is T you fuzen
squared you get the option classifier
and this idea of just assuming at the
top there's some learning algorithm that
is doing something you like the caption
classifier computing averages across
classes and giving you a predictive
function this way but you can replace
that with any other classifier that you
can back propagate it's just a Gaussian
glass car because it's just computing
averages pretty simple people that
looked at assuming it's actually a least
square classifier so one that
essentially treats classification as a
regression problem linear regression
problem doesn't have submission for
instance here meddling with the stretch
of all closed form solvers where they
and in general they're making the point
that if you have a cool full room solver
of the learning algorithm you can back
propagate through it so do something
else than that and that is an
interesting direction and a low to make
sense there's like a whole lot of other
classifiers we could back propagate to
through at this point but so what about
not forgetting to like for people
looking at I'm not sure I can
give an example right now I mean the
answer given the recent archives it's
almost yes but I doubt I can point you
to what they've got any publicity that's
true but so III don't have one reference
I wouldn't be surprised if it didn't
work because I think there's a lot of
value to doing like gradient descent end
to end maybe if you pre trying in the
regular way it's possible that some RL
based fine tunings would be sufficient I
mean one problem with that crop is for
Katie's large numbers then there's her
back buttons anything that work we'll
talk about mammal in a few seconds but I
think I think that I think it's worth
investigating but probably he wanted the
first free trade model what's
interesting also is that in the typical
network paper they actually get better
results by training on more weight so if
they're in all these EPS I showed it was
always five-point constipation so way is
the number of classes Jonathas number of
examples per class in the experiments
they showed that if they tried form 20
weight classification they met a
friendly community classification but
the evaluate for five-way classification
they tend to got better results to get
better result
so and there are other people there's
this element a I think they're also that
is doing this sort of leave one out type
of meta learning where they have
evidence that this works better as well
and I think the the reason I mentioned
this is that it is not entirely clear
that the wing but so far evidence
suggests that the way to you who manage
for
does not necessarily need to reflect
perfectly the way that you actually
evaluate your learning out of them and
that hints at difficulties of doing
optimization potentially in for these
metal learning methods and that we don't
have a good understanding the other
point so another extension of
prototypical Network another beautiful
element they are appearing lips this
year and it's extending from a typical
network by making the embedding function
that you apply on your examples a
function of the training set or support
set the episode and they do this
essentially using film they take the set
of supports that example the training
set and then the IPT get prototypes in
the regular prototypical Network wave
and then the average the prototypes
themselves and just be someone here
knows this more than I do
dated me so correct me if I'm wrong no
sorry that's great that gives you a task
representation the average of the task
representation is the average of the
prototypes and this is that fed into a
network that produces the as in film the
sort of bias and multiplicative factor
that will now be gating I believe the
same embedding function and there might
be other components as well later on and
they've shown that they get better
results on media business by doing this
which is again taking a bit more into
account the sort of step structure of
the training set here compared to a
regular for a typical Network and they
also show that when we do this thing
where they go for embedding function to
be useful for a regular 64 way
classification and who this episode ik
training that they get better results
they don't do it by just doing pre
training and then
initializing these weights do just a
regular meta learning procedure other
people have done that and found that
useful in their case
actually the paper says that that wasn't
that successful as it's sort of more
gradual sort of mixing in regular 64
reclassification and episode they face
tragedy so I don't know why but
apparently there can be other better
ways of that have come by the regular
type of training and embedding function
all right what else yes it always
increased over just way and that's
usually a baseline so otherwise it's a
point but you're normally then you do
get additional perform against in
performance these are always like way
better but there is an improvement also
there's an interesting view of for a
typical networks where if you're using
the square in pleasing distance when
you're comparing for the types and
examples you can expand that into
essentially an expression which is the
embedding of the test example times the
prototype because it's a square function
and you can expand the term and then
then there's a bias term which is
essentially the prototype times the
prototype square norm of the prototype
if you think of these effectively and
think of these as the output bias and
wait for that class if you were using
the embedding as the rest of the network
it's kind of like prototypical networks
which is producing the parameters of the
output layer of a network with a soft
max output and other people have looked
at generalizing that effectively and
actually have a network resume saying
say convolutional filters directly of a
neural net so this 2016 nips paper was
doing that for C developing a different
set of problems but at some quick result
and so I just want to put it out there
that the one approach is Jack some
neural net that produces parameters not
for grading the set or anything like
that but through some diffraction
and there's also a relationship with
graft neural network so some people have
just thought of the training set as a
essentially fully connected graph and
using graph neural networks to propagate
the labeled information of the examples
in the training set towards producing a
prediction of the label or a test
example that would also be part of that
graph I don't have its label out this
was an IQ paper earlier this year which
you might want to check out I won't go
into details but that's another if
you're doing graph neural nets there
might be interesting applications here
all right and then I think probably the
final thing I'll touch on is the other
approach for designing a metal learner
which is to take inspiration from
gradient descent so the idea here is to
kind of notice that when we're doing
gradient descent which is D sort of
almost universal algorithm always use
almost to fit the model to a training
set what we're doing is that we have a
set of parameters and we are dating it
using this linear equation that involves
the gradients of the training set
examples with respect to my thorough set
of drug that gives me the next value for
the parameters or that pass and then a
direct is some number so in this paper
that we published like 2017 we kind of
made the connection between that and
what is the latent the cell state of an
MST m4l SCM also does these kind of
additive updates of the cell state where
the cell state is x forget these and
then you add to this a contribution to
the state x and implicit and if you
think of if the sub state contribution
was the negative gradient in some
parameter space and if the input gate
was the learning rate and if you didn't
have a forget gate and you recover the
equations of gradient descent which
essentially suggests that we can unroll
like we unroll record neural net so less
damage we could unroll great in the
sense of
and that propagate through them and in
our case we try to stay as close as we
could to the lsdm study where we have in
less DM where its tell state is as large
as the number of parameters in my model
so for image net this would be a cog net
and then I have these input gates and
these forget agates are effectively
producing a learning rate for each of
the parameters and we also kept the
forget gate thinking that they might
apply some form of recognization if it's
shrinking the parameters toward zero
then that's kind of like saying windy
day and then we can unroll this don't
want the N squared parameters that's
right but what we do is that the set of
parameters that produces the learning
rate and is shrinking the forget K for
each per hour or its parameter of my cup
that so that lsdm is the same across all
from so you can think of it as it's
learning the same optimizer that's
applied across all parameters of my
country so there's a form of parameter
sharing going on also what we will do is
that instead of using as the initial
starting point of my gradient descent
will actually learn it so this is like
the initial cell States T 0 so in this
context of meta learning that's dead of
0 theta 0 will be learnt so we're going
to learn the initialization such that
after a few steps of gradient descent
that is modulated by MLS TM we're going
to reach a model that has good
generalization on the test set of the
episode there are others that people
learning and thank you so that's sort of
the graph view what I've just described
you have it's lsdm in this manner and at
the end that I think initial state the
initial parameters of my ComNet that is
0 looks at what is my performance of the
support set or the training set on my
episode produces gradients that are fed
to the Mellen learner so that it can
produce a new suggested value of the
parameters of my campus my model and any
valid that evaluate that again on my
training set and I do this some number
of
and then ultimately and look at what is
the performance of the test set of the
episode and that's what I that's the
error that I got propagate through this
whole chain of this whole unrolled graph
of a few other things that I mentioned
that I haven't mentioned yet doing some
form of reprocessing of the gradient
that is fed to the ASTM has been found
to be useful you can look at the
learning to learn by gradient descent is
a paper from be fine or they use the
similar things to actually learn in
optimizer that for future learning but
there are things where like going more
in the log space and actually those
operating each grade II component into
terms that such here what's gone ruffle
yes so actually in this setting because
weekly shop learning what that means is
that the training step is very strong I
can do full full batch gradients so I
can actually calculate the grain from
the full training set if the trace of
was larger than indeed I would need to
impose some sort of work when this
setting actually cause that really
stochastic gradient descent
I'm unrolling regular crate in this
batch Creek dependence in know what I'm
saying is that x1 and y1 is the same
across all these steps in few shop
learning because I can take the full
training set otherwise if it was
actually not so if you shop learning
like a thousand examples then perhaps I
would want to split in two batches and
then there would be decision naturally
the way I would address that is I would
just shuffle the order for everything
and then you might consider actually a
meta test time when the anomaly name
just apply the same procedure so I'm
essentially moving you forward pastel
STM on the bunch of random orderings of
the same
matches and then create an in-sample and
I would be surprised if that was better
than any individual supporter of any and
then of a few months after this paper I
Chelsea fin from Berkeley proposed to
essentially just scrap the lsdm shoes
actually regular grain in the set with a
constant learning rate they'll learn the
initialization so that's really
important and she shows you got to like
just as good results and in fact is bad
and so that's called mammal model and
Gnostic meta learning I think the reason
it's agnostic is that doesn't matter
whether you're you want to do meta
learning assuming the model is they're
confident or any other type of model as
long as it has a parameterised space you
can find that well to metal learn it in
the fuchsia learning setting and also
there's an improvement that's reported
in this paper that's called bias
transformation where in addition to
learn in addition to learn the
initialization of the weights and
devices of all the layers of the
continent you also append to some of the
layers or all layers a parameter that
instead of you and which ask connections
that goes into the next layer and you
also learn that parameter vector and so
it's actually adding other parameters to
level other parameters to the meta
learning they essentially the argument
that they're making is that this sort of
decouples some of the gradients that are
being back propagated during learning
this kind of decouples the way that the
weights are being updated and devices of
being updated in the male learners for
more you should look at the paper it's
called bias transformation i i've never
tried it myself but if you have for some
reason difficulties having success with
model that's a thing you should consider
doing and effectively all it does is
that it adds
parameters to novel
also what's interesting is that for a
single gradient descent step so here
when we unroll in practice we unroll for
five steps and steps very few step
because otherwise the draft becomes too
big you have to unpack propagate through
too many updates and so actually
interestingly in my clear paper earlier
this year does she show that the single
gradient descent update is enough to
make your meta learner a universal
approximator of any of these
distribution of the label of a new test
example given the training step which is
somewhat surprising I think we would
expect that many updates would be
required she demonstrated that in the
context of using the bias transformation
and using and for neural net using relu
units yeah no I mean I read it sort of
loosely once seemed to make sense by
knowing the details I mean if someone
wants to demonstrate it it's wrong and
would be interesting but that wasn't I
think it's surprising to some extent but
at the same time I think the reason this
works is that what are you doing this
one step of gradient descent and you're
fitting that model you're kind of
repurposing some of the parameters of
that content some of them will be
effectively used to propagate gradients
perhaps in the nice way for lower layers
and there's still enough expressivity in
the full learner if you allow it to be
as big as one to potentially even
separate like a back from pathway and
therefore from pathway so I think the
argument ultimately means that if you
take something as back box as a neural
net and you just make it very very large
you're bound to get some sort of
universal approximation demonstrating it
isn't that fairly easy but in this case
yeah as arguments for why that is
theoretically in general it is true that
one step great in the Zen Trammell is
actually surprisingly effective but in
practice on medium Internet people use
more like five and I think often they
shrink for just five but actually
yes with like 20 so again it's an
interesting case of sort of training
differently than you actually invest and
there's a relationship between nominal
and doing sort of some form of proper
article Bayesian inference and there's a
relationship between a lot of these no
learning approaches and just a fission
perspective we have a fryer over
effectively models and you're adjusting
the steer for given training set in fact
the Josh Tenenbaum paper is effectively
like a Bayesian take on middle learning
and so that's something that was
published that I clear earlier this year
as well it might draw more clearer like
direct a relationship between the two
and then and I think and with this and
recently on archive and destination at
AI clear of 2019 people have tried to
sort of investigate various variations
of mammal that seems to stabilize
learning so mammal is in general it
takes a lot of memory because your graph
actually has multiple copies of the
model when you're unrolled gradient
descent steps so that's one thing that's
annoying about it
but in other one is I guess it's
something I sort of alluded to when we
compute gradients that we feed that or
when we have these equations that
involve the gradients on the parameters
when you're doing that learning then you
need to great ends up that degree so you
need second-order ingredients brain or
military with math that's like an older
brain can be expensive to compute if
you're not careful and in general it
does just will necessarily sort of slow
the forward and backward paths of battle
and so people have used instead the
second-order version of mammal which
essentially applying a stop gradient on
the on that gradient integrated descend
recursion in the inner loop of apples
essentially just saying that this
gradient that you're passing to the
mechanism that provides an update don't
actually back drop through that and stop
the gradient and that's sometimes works
sometimes doesn't
it often makes trading more unstable and
and so at this paper metal plus class
there's a bunch of tricks that they
looked at where it seems according to
them that they're really stabilizing
training so these three courtesy are
they're mammal plus plus they're call it
four different seats and these curves
here are their regular sort of
presumably first order model that I
don't remember it might still be
second-order by that this first program
and some of the tricks that they use is
that if you're doing Kings steps of
gradient descent at every iteration you
actually have parameters that you can
evaluate you know is it actually a good
concept or the text as of the episode
you can do that at every step and so
what they suggest is to actually
minimize some weighted sum of the
performance across all steps okay so
instead of in this figure here only
looking at the loss on the test set of
the episode only at the very end you
actually do it at every time step in the
inner loop every time instead I want
data to and so on and doing some sort of
waiting and even propose some way of
having kind of a curriculum or early
young you put more weight on the first
steps but then later on more weight on
the next steps they also proposed
starting with just doing first order
battle and then eventually actually
using a full order version after some
number of iterations so in other words
use first order model to kind of
initialize regular full order battle
actually training the learning rates
that is being used
Dunsey I mentioned that it's using
constant step size learning rate for
every step so it's constant across time
steps and it's constant across
parameters they found that if you have a
different learning rate for each time
step and a different one for the trapars
of each layer that they get better
performance this way and in this case
they actually do great in descent also
on these learning rates I mean no it's
just you're adding that it is still a
parameter so it's not the learning rate
on the NAM all parameters it's the inner
loop it's that's it's like it's
essentially
part of this update mechanism here so
it's it's it's a gradient descent step
on this guy
whereas lateral often this constant
state comes in step learning rate is
often treated as a hybrid program that
you just scribe various values for other
things when you're doing batch nor
instead of using regular bathroom you
actually just assume you're always using
them when you're running the training of
Babel you are using the running
statistics over the batches which means
you're essentially ignoring some of the
gradients that would come from there and
actually also having third time step
batch alone parameters so for every time
step you got to have a different set of
batch number others that's the gamma and
the beta and training dose as well so
this adds just a few parameters but
apparently all of these together sort of
allows for more stable training I don't
think this paper has a particularly
exhaustive ablation study at least when
I looked at it so what extent all of
these are necessary I'm not exactly sure
but I'm mentioning them because again if
you probably use family for some problem
these are good sort of directions to
investing all right so I'm already out
of time I won't go over this but I know
I said I'm happy to sort of do it part
with this top one thing I wanted to
quickly mention but don't and already
just with this like you have a good
sense of what are the state-of-the-art
methods that people use to be comparable
in fact just did they added some slides
of things that people actively
publishing and send you right clear this
year and so on in terms of the future
challenges I think the directions that
are interesting are how to have I'll do
identify the issues that we're finding
when we're optimizing on some definition
of episodes for training where maybe we
use more ways or less ways for the same
I totally don't quite understand all of
that setup and so and also I think
designing a more realistic more
large-scale benchmark
medium is that something actively we're
doing by group right now we're hoping to
eventually release where we actually
would have an evaluation procedure that
admit a test time you have different
data sets but least within your whole
bench more if you have different data
sets from different sources I think
that's a natural next step that
hopefully I'll be able to share some of
that I'm going beyond just supervised
classification there's a bunch of paper
that going to point people to maybe in
the next part or just talk but people
are looking at milling for or clustering
for distribution estimation or a
structured prediction and segmentation
there's a lot of other applications out
there using some of these basic ideas
that I talked about today and ultimately
what what I think is interesting is
really this interactive setting where a
user provides a small training set that
they can provide just needs to be small
you can manually label there could be
some examples gets a model and then
based on that may be corrected by
providing new example kind of like the
video I showed earlier that's not really
the setting in which we're investigating
these ideas but I think ultimately
that's the setting where you want to be
in and so I think people that look at
things like doing meta active learning
so suggesting to the user to label
certain points and learning how to make
that active learning learning that
active foreign policy with I would say
mixed results like some positive some
less positive but I think ultimately
that would be quite interesting
direction and with that thank you
[Applause]